Bob Nightingale legendary columnist from
USA Today he told us that Bob joins us
from Phoenix he was at the Giants
Diamondbacks game and he'll see the
Phillies take on the Diamondbacks then
he's going to Barry Bonds retirement
ceremony on Saturday
Bob good morning thanks for joining us
what do you expect to happen at Barry
Bonds retirement ceremony I'll just be a
wild you can work weekend well people go
nuts and say why isn't this kind of Hall
of Fame I think it'll be just a huge
love fest and this guy meant everything
that franchise do you think he says that
does he use the platform to say anything
about the Hall of Fame I don't think he
does
I think I'll say you know what this is
awesome if I if I get into the Hall of
Fame
it's great if not so be it but I don't I
don't think he'll send a message here I
really don't all right a couple of
things here Mike Scioscia is stepping
down at the end of the season or at
least those are the reports you wrote
that he wanted to do this quietly but
the timing of this with these young
talents like Shohei Otani and Mike Trout
I found surprising but why is Mike
Scioscia stepping down you know just 19
years and the only guy who has a longer
tenure right now is the big papa vision
of the Spurs and I just think is being
them up you know the pitching staffs
been in disarray for years I'm not sure
that you can they can contend next year
either and I just think he's had enough
you know he's told his friends told his
family I don't want to manage after this
you know maybe change his mind a few
years I don't think me a special
assistant nothing I think just going to
vacation and Europe and do fun things
these not available do after his playing
career you know in managerial career
like let's have some fun in life how
coveted is this job
oh very coveted I mean you're in you
know you're in Anaheim you know
beautiful area and you got Mike Trout on
your team you got alcohol a favor and
pull balls to get Otani
so I think the only upper we've got
hundreds of resumes
but it's interesting Eric Chavez the
former former all-star third baseman you
going to start managing at that Salt
Lake you know this final monk here and
you got a Brad Ausmus also in that
organization the former Tigers manager
so you got to you know great in-house
candidates right there well I'm with
Josh Paul the best coach if I gave you
the Red Sox or the field this year
how would you take a feel then just I
mean Houston is so good I know the
resdac sort of you know historic taste
everything else but that ass rotation is
just unbelievable and kind of Dark
Horse's Cleveland people forget about
how good Cleveland is I mean Cleveland's
got a chance to surprise people too so I
still think the World Series goes
through Houston just because that
rotation yeah I like Cleveland being
sneaky great - how close were they to
getting Bryce Harper in your opinion I
don't think okay I think you're the
Nationals at trade a Harper just been
such an embarrassing season I'm
everything it's been the most
embarrassing I've ever had because they
have more talent than nationally and
they're not playing like it you know
they're hanging around but they
shouldn't be chasing the Phillies in
Atlanta Braves
you know you trade Harper you're not
gonna get them back either
it's like when they Arendt Sox doesn't
get reassigned Jon Lester once less or
less because you know what I found out
you know B there's that the World Series
I think it'll let Harper go he would be
gone for every well Aaron judges wrist
seems like a little bit more of a
problem here than the Yankees thought
what is what is the prognosis with that
I mean he's still supposed to be back by
the end of month I mean now they're so
far behind the Yankees just like you
know why push it too much and you know
any hand or wrist injury to hit her
can be a nightmare that's what's going
on here they just want to be very very
cautious and make sure that you know
when he comes back yeah he stays back
you know he's showing right now what he
means that Club because they're not
there is not the same team without him
yeah but you're trying to as you said
you know you're basically out of the
race now
nine and a half games back you know
there's no rush to bring Aaron judge
back anytime soon is there there's not
although you gotta be a little careful
with the open channel playing what they
are I mean Oakland is just two and a
half games back in the wild-card so they
got to be a little cautious I mean the
schedule leads up and everything else
and they do play Boston at six seven
times the last few weeks I mean by then
you know Red Sox will have it so sewn up
where they can just kind of relax and
Yankees win some games know will still
get a wild-card spot but they can't let
up on the panel too much you were
talking about the teams in the American
League the Red Sox Astros Indians best
team in the National League Dodgers
Dodgers are Cubs almost a coin flip I
don't like the Dodgers you know outside
killing Jansen I think they have a hole
there in the back in the bullpen where
the Cubs have those guys so almost
equivalent between the two but the
difference between the two leagues now
looks like it's like wintermint double-a
going into where the NIT I mean it's
just such a huge disparity between the
two leagues
I'm gonna bet score five teams in
baseball or all America would good stuff
Bob thank you as always and have fun at
Barry Bonds retirement ceremony on
Saturday okay thank you buddy thank you
Bob Bob nightingale USA Today columnist
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]